welcome everybody good afternoon it's
nice to be inside and this is the 2010
journalism school graduation ceremony
for family members students that have
not met I'm Nick lemon the Dean and I
want to start on a logistical note by
saying that in case the ecstasy at the
end is too out of control for you to
listen afterward the kind of after party
to this is indoors today unlike how it
usually is it's on the fifth floor of
this building you go out and up and if
you're hale and hearty I would advise
taking those ramps you've been looking
at all year because the elevator
capacity in this building is very very
limited but you go all the way to the
top and there's this wonderful room and
you'll find food drink etc so we we
traditionally begin this ceremony as I
warned you yesterday with a few remarks
by me so here goes and they will be
brief one of the distinctive aspects of
Columbia Journalism school is that the
great majority of our students are here
for only one year as all of you in the
audience know it's a peculiar it's a
peculiar peculiarly intense year as if
we had figured out how to distill the
more languorous time to degree at all
the other schools of Columbia down to a
powerful essence still speaking for
myself I wish our clothes
acquaintanceship were not so brief and i
hope you will endeavor to extend it by
becoming from the moment of receiving
your diplomas forward highly engaged and
active alumni we're here for you long
after today there's one advantage for me
however to our short course to degree
every year I open our graduation
ceremony with a few brief remarks like
this and if I repeat myself from year to
year very few members of the audience
will notice last year I urged our
graduates to get involved in the larger
conversation about the future of
journalism that is now taking place very
intensely in societies all
the world a conversation that is going
on not just within the confines of the
profession as was customary before the
digital revolution arrived this year i
would like to deliver a similar but more
pointed message if you heard me last
year well sorry but as my mother used to
say it bears repeating just after i
arrived here is Dean seven years ago I
got a phone call from a senior at
Harvard who was writing a thesis about
the media reform movement the folks who
push for government policies meant to
reduce the scope of big media companies
she wanted to know why there never
seemed to be any journalists involved in
that movement activities either as
supporters or his opponents it was a
good question media reforms simply isn't
on most journalists minds even though
many or most of us work for media
companies or would like to why not I
think it's because we like to conceive
of ourselves as independent solo
Crusaders who go out uncover
uncomfortable truths and resolutely
bring them to the public's attention all
we need to be able to do this is freedom
but what makes our idea of ourselves
more complicated now is that at least in
the United States with the advent of the
open Internet we don't lack for the
freedom to say what we want what we
urgently need more of is economic
support for the kind of dogged reporting
that at least at this school we hold up
as the sinequan on of great journalism
journalists of my generation grew up
believing that the best way to get the
support was just by demanding it from
rich owners but now owners of
journalistic properties aren't quite so
rich so whom do we ask many years ago
when he was a law professor Lee
Bollinger the president of this
university used to write that the United
States had a dual press system with an
unregulated realm print and a regulated
realm broadcast both the newspapers and
the
outkast outlets usually had a highly
protected monopoly position in their
markets at least at the time Bollinger
was writing which made them very
profitable and therefore able to support
journalism in the digital age president
Bollinger 'he's distinction doesn't
really hold anymore most journalism is
consumed online and most of us get
online through a system that government
touches a cable line telephone wire a
satellite so even though it may not
appear that way to you journalism is
deeply unentertaining and the way
government business and technology have
set up the playing field the folks who
carry the signal to your computer make
money and the folks who create the
material that the signal carries meaning
among others us do not there is an
intense debate going on right this
minute about government policies that
will have enormous effects on the future
of journalism the media of reform
movement as always is mainly focused on
limiting the power of big media
companies and on improving public access
therefore its main causes regarding the
Internet are universal broadband access
so that everybody everywhere can have
fast service and net neutrality so that
Internet service providers have to
continue giving every user equal access
to every website Internet service
providers as always are pushing back
against the media reform movement and
journalists are almost nowhere to be
found in this debate one of the few
journalism organizations to answer a
recent call from the Federal
Communications Commission to comment on
the future of our business was the radio
television and digital news association
whose public comment pronounced the
state of commercial broadcast journalism
to be just fine and ended on this
libertarian note I'm quoting the
Commission should not accede to calls
from those who would have the government
tell the public what is best for them or
who would integrate the government and
the
press that would deal a far greater blow
to our democracy than any perceived and
i want to emphasize they say perceived
contraction in journalism unquote if
there were formers win this round then
most americans will be able to go
anywhere they want in the vast reaches
of the World Wide Web but I'm far less
optimistic than the RT DNA that
journalists will have the economic means
of producing journalism we could wind up
with a situation that's an exaggerated
version of what we have now more access
less real repertrio journalism let's
assume that everybody in this room wants
to see our profession have the resources
it needs to perform its function in
society to the fullest where will the
resources come from most of the
discussion about the fabled new business
model for journalism whose arrival we
are all eagerly awaiting seems to be
turning to the idea of restricting the
regime of absolutely free access to all
journalism produced everywhere that
we've had over these last few years news
organizations websites will mainly begin
charging for access new tablet style
mobile devices will probably charge
readers from the get-go and advertisers
may find readers who can and do pay to
be up to reach I'm sorry and advertisers
be a more attractive audience than
easily distractible web surfers even if
this all works economically and I
certainly hope it does it will still
represent a departure from the current
socially attractive and economically
untenable idea that the fruits of our
journalistic labor should be available
free to all the citizens of the world so
one could argue that economic support
for journalism is a public good and
should be funded from sources in
addition to the free market as for
example universities like Columbia fund
themselves partly through the free
market
pay your tuition checks and partly from
other sources maybe internet service
providers should be compelled to set
aside some money for news production as
broadcasters in effect used to be before
broadcast deregulation or maybe the
public radio and television systems
should get funding to do more original
local reporting or maybe philanthropy
should fund journalism or maybe
government itself should with
appropriate firewalls to protect
editorial freedom as it has with high
distinction in some other countries
these are not abstract ideas from a
seminar room they are intensely and
urgently under discussion right now in
Washington and much of the rest of the
world but mainly without the
participation of journalists and i
should add they are not being discussed
behind closed doors in washington
they're being discussed behind open
doors in washington and you still have a
tremendously hard time getting
journalists to participate in these
discussions i'm using my few minutes at
the podium today to urge you as strongly
as i can not only to go out and be great
journalists but also to learn about and
engage in the realm of public policy
that affects our profession there will
be decisions made in just the next few
years that will profoundly affect the
way you do your work over the many
decades of your careers you really
shouldn't let them be made without us
collectively in the room the idea that
journalists somehow sully themselves if
they become active participants in
shaping the future of our profession
isn't just silly it's dangerous if you
believe journalism is as vital to the
health of free societies as I think we
all do as young journalists you are
standing at the doorway to a new period
in our profession whose nature is still
being determined journalists always get
to witness history unfolding that's one
of the great attractions of our
profession you will also get to witness
the history of journalism unfolding more
dramatically than most of us
sitting up here on the stage have please
don't let yourselves be on the receiving
end of history be participants in it
thank you
now i'm going to call to the podium the
spj advisor Rebecca Castillo Rebecca is
assistant director of the Columbia
scholastic Press Association a venerable
organization that works with budding
high school journalists in fact that was
one of my first touch points to
journalism many many years ago Rebecca
is a graduate and former class president
herself and she will introduce our
student speaker Rebecca
Society of Professional Journalists is
an international organization of
reporters for broadcast print digital
media and photo journalists who support
each other and provide examples of the
best practices of journalism they remind
us to hold ourselves to the higher
standards of ethics integrity and
getting the story right as well as
advocate the protection of the First
Amendment and its guarantees of freedom
of speech and the press through its
advocacy efforts at the Columbia
Graduate School journalism we have a
student chapter of spj which is also the
de facto student government all the
officers are elected at the beginning of
the fall term and at this time I'd like
to ask all spj members to stand and be
acknowledged for the hard work this year
this year your class elected siddharth
philip as the class president and one of
my first conversations was Sid I found
out that he passed up a full scholarship
to Berkeley to choose our school when I
asked him why he chose the j-school he
responded very simply it was never
question in his mind he wanted to learn
from the best Sid has has received a job
and will be gainfully employed with
Bloomberg News in mumbai india following
graduation ladies and gentlemen classes
class president 2010 said
good afternoon ladies gentlemen and the
class of 2010 at the outset I want to
mention especially the Dean Sri that I
tried to keep this page to 140
characters actually less but it turned
out to be more difficult than landing a
plane in the Hudson this year has been a
crazy one for the first part I realized
that the school then informed me in
March last year that housing was not
really necessary given that I spent most
of the year sleeping on the couches on
the fifth floor and in the student
center I really didn't need to fork out
so much in rent apart from friending
each other on linkedin and facebook and
attending happy hours at ten-twenty and
lions head we actually managed to get a
surprising amount of work done this year
the mandatory digital media bootcamp rw1
assignments in other classes come to
think of it this year was so intense
that at some point I even give up
reading the newspaper
during the year which has been
overwhelming for most almost everyone at
the school we met with tons of
journalists bloggers and even the guy
who tweeted about the Hudson plane crash
almost everyone we met has an opinion
about journalism some even talk about
how journalism is dying and the internet
had having killed any value the news is
to have but the more I look at it the
more I realized that is far from a dead
profession in fact it's more important
than ever in a world where rumors have
an even faster way of getting around a
world that is getting increasingly
intolerant and one where news from one
of its corners can have a massive
ramification seven oceans away and as
journalists this is the most exciting
time to be in the profession our
generation or maybe the next will be the
ones that hopefully discover the right
model for the business in today's
interconnected world our school's
founder Joseph Pulitzer had great faith
in the importance of journalism and its
role as a Fourth Estate of government
and his reason for founding our school
was his belief that the power to mold
the future of the Republic will be in
the hands of journalists of future
generations or at least that's what the
University wanted to put up on the wall
in these trying times in these trying
times when everyone seems to be
dismissing journalism as a dead
profession on all of us are struggling
to be employed our founder inspires us
not to give in to the tales of the sky
falling this has been the most fantastic
year of my life I really mean it I'd
like to thank each and every faculty
member the deans the administration and
most of all my colleagues from the class
of 2010 thank you
Thanks said Joseph Pulitzer did actually
write that by the way that the future of
the Republic so we're very ethical about
what we put up on the walls around here
now those of you who brave the bed
weather and went to the University
commencement this morning yes you're
very Hardy people and you saw the
honorary degrees presented which is you
know very wonderful and thrilling but
there's one disadvantage which is that
only president Bollinger is allowed to
confer honorary degrees and the deans
are not allowed to confer them however
if individual schools were allowed to
confer honorary degrees the Columbia
Journalism Award would be our under
honorary degree and in fact it's even
better than a university honorary degree
because there's only one recipient per
year so we really have to put our marker
down on somebody it's chosen by a vote
of the faculty every year a quote for
singular journalistic performance in the
public interest and is presented
annually to someone of overarching
accomplishment and distinguished service
to journalism this year's award winner
is Gail Collins who is here
before invite Gail to the podium I'm
going to read a brief introduction
although I shouldn't need much of an
introduction in this crowd Gail Collins
joined the new york times in 1995 as a
member of the editorial board and later
is not bad columnist in 2001 she became
the first woman ever appointed editor of
The Times editorial pages at the
beginning of 2007 she stepped down and
began leave in order to finish a sequel
to her book America's women 400 years of
dolls drudges help mates and heroines
she returned to the times as a columnist
you know because you do read the times
except Sid in july two thousand seven
before joining the times miss Collins
was a comest at New York Newsday and the
New York Daily News and a reporter for
United Press International her first
jobs and journalism were in Connecticut
where she founded the Connecticut State
News Bureau which provided coverage of
the state capitol and Connecticut
politics when she sold it in 1977 the
csn be was the largest news news service
of its kind in the country with more
than 30 weekly and daily newspaper
chains besides America's women which is
published in 2003 miss Collins is the
author of scorpion tongues gossip
celebrity in American politics and the
millennium book was she co-authored with
their husband dan collins her new book
is about American women since nineteen
sixty and then I'll get to her really
important credentials which are there
less important be a from marquette
university ma from UMass Amherst and
then rising up the credential scale
master of science and journalism from
Columbia Journalism school
where she was a badgett fellow in the
class of the 1981-82 a school year and
then the pinnacle achievement of her
career adjunct professor at Columbia
Journalism school where with seth lipsky
she's taught the opinion writing course
this year Gail we have a sort of a dance
with the presentation and you and the
speech and so on so you can figure out
where to put this thing it's pretty
heavy congratulations
thank you this is like a lethal weapon
god this is a serious piece of marble or
something here thank you so much it is
so good it's so nice to see a rowdy
group at a graduation too I like this a
lot go for it I say yes and this is your
day I mean you know all day long you
should celebrate you know be difficult
and I dinner tell your family long
stories about people they've never heard
of before you know eat their desserts
just do everything you want because this
is absolutely your day you know I
searched for suggestions on how to give
a proper commencement speech and I have
distilled all the advice I got down to
four rules which I'm prepared to follow
the first is to be brief that is not
going to be a problem because when I
graduated from college I was totally
traumatized by our graduation speaker
who is a very prominent diplomat whose
name I will not repeat but he talked for
like an hour and a half I swear and
every time anyone mentioned my diploma
after that my father would sort of
whimper and quiver a little bit although
it was actually a good thing for me
because I can tell you this because
we're in such an intimate group where
things will never get out i'm sure i
didn't actually graduate with my class
this is a true story I got an incomplete
in ethics of journalism made it up later
second suggestion was to give helpful
career tips so I worked up five and
these really are the best I could think
of first of all when you send out your
clips send out the ones with the best
leads because editors have very short
attention spans true fact number two
once you get the job figure out your
goal what assignment you want next and
then tell your editor repeatedly your
editor does not know where you should be
going next your editor does not know
really he's not thinking about anything
about trustee your editor does not know
has no earthly idea so you figure it out
for yourself and then a
as long as possible number three try to
write for anybody who asks you at
minimum it gives you the kind of
practice in writing that you would get
if you were keeping those journals that
people like me keep urging you to keep
which I never kept but it did sound like
a really good idea and you can never
tell when any assignment I truly believe
this you can never tell when somebody
asked you to write something no matter
how peculiar it is what it's going to
lead to it could be anything I have to
tell you that this line of thinking this
truly did in the 80s leave me to become
a correspondent for some period of time
for the polyester news I swear you have
no idea how many things can be written
about polyester it just goes on never
say anything never this is very very
very important especially if you write
for a newspaper never say that anything
is the oldest or the biggest or the
longest I promise you there's a reader
in Indiana who knows of something that
is older or bigger or longer and he will
drive you crazy and finally when you've
established yourself and a popular
magazine calls and says that they're
dying to have something written in your
voice understand this probably means
they're dying to have something written
in your voice and then rewritten in
their voice that's all I can tell you on
that point completely the third rule for
a commencement speak speech I think from
ones I've read and listen to his that I
should tell you an expiring anecdote
from my life which on which point I am
totally screwed completely I got into
this business during the great woman's
movement and I arrived in New York
approximately one second after women had
filed the suits at places like the new
york times in newsweek who had protested
who had demonstrated who had gotten in
the face of the editors and had forced
the male editors the time to create a
new gender-free industry from the bottom
to almost possibly the very almost top
at this point
anyway they did it they were the
heroines I came in one second later the
women who did those present who did
those suits the women who did those
protests who were the heroines of the
story did not get the rewards people
like me who came right after them got
the rewards people who had not filed the
protest or guttin in the face of the
editors and so on and so forth I know
the women who came right before me who
did those things and they're not bitter
they are still pissed at their papers I
have to say that but they're happy about
what happened they were really really
rejoice and all the things that have
happened to women since their time all
the places women have gone and the
profession all the things they've done
and for me that is the definition of a
great heart somebody who can take joy in
somebody else's success at something
that you meant to win that ahead of time
and didn't it's just and this profession
that you're going into is full of people
with great hearts many of them are
eccentric to the point of insanity but
they are amazing amazing brave smart
daring people and I cannot tell you how
lucky you are to be going into the
profession where there are so many of
them I cannot tell you how lucky I feel
to have been in a profession that he
have hit that I've met so many of them
over the years this brings me and I
can't tell you in a bottom line is I'm
not going to tell you my best story
which is the one about how I got a
unisex bathroom and the fifth floor of
the state capital in Connecticut which
was really the best thing I did for my
sex the entire time I was working there
but some other time we'll get back to
that the final and important the most
important requirement for a commencement
speech and this is the one that's the
center of all of them i think really is
the description of the exciting
opportunities that await the graduates
you think that's going to be a problem
for me it's not hahaha I've got it I
truly believe it's Nick was talking
before I truly absolutely believe
there's going to be a complete explosion
of terrific journalism in your
generation because partly because
there's so much need for coverage of so
many aspects of our lives that have been
completely agree
word for so long particularly local
government state government
neighborhoods Foreign Affairs small
countries that never get covered and
less my colleague Nick Kristof shows up
there one day all this stuff is dying to
be covered out there all that we're
lacking we've got plenty of stuff to do
all that we're lacking is a method of
making money off the content of the web
and I am absolutely sure that's coming I
do not know anything about technology
nick has thought about this ten times
more than I have but I am very good at
history and I have noticed that one way
or another consumers always wind up
paying for stuff that they want
corporations always win in the end and
amazingly at this point we're on the
side of the corporation's I think this
positions us very well in the United
States of America for future success so
I truly believe this is going to work
out but in the meantime I would advise
all of you to find partners who have
good health benefits of their job that's
for the partners out there but in return
for your trouble I just want to talk a
minute about what you're going to get
and you're going to get to fill the
unmet needs of all that coverage of
state government local government of
foreign countries that are being totally
completely ignored all the time of
neighborhoods of serious endeavors from
medicine to highway construction all
that is goes without saying I have to
say but you're also going to do
something else that I have thought about
a lot and that is that you guys are
going to invent a whole new form of
communication that doesn't even exist
right now in my time I always found the
technology had a profound effect on what
we wrote I think this is true throughout
history in my time two big things happen
one was that the typewriter gave way to
the word processor and then the computer
and when that happened the writing
changed if PKM is I swear to you chris /
it was less dense you know before that I
think you all know you heard enough
about people like me telling you the
stuff
you got a typewriter and you took five
pieces of paper and five carbons in
between the pieces of paper and you
typed one big massive bulky thing this
was not something you were going to
tinker with once you were done this was
pretty much the way it was going to be
you know you might send it to a copy
editor who would get rid of the most
incoherent sentences but that's about
all that was going to happen for you
with a computer the thinking did not get
any deeper the but the writing did
become smoother humor was easier and
shorter was much easier and that was
very important because the other great
technological change in my time was the
arrival and total taking over of culture
by television and when TV arrived
attention spans started to shrink
instantly until they reached the
approximate size of a gnat's I think by
the time they were done if you look at
the papers in the 40s and the 50s and
see how formal the writing is how dense
the writing is you realize that the
people who were writing knew that their
readers were not going to go anywhere
they were stuck the readers had no
choice unless they wanted to stare at
the walls or something they had them by
the neck and the change came slowly the
suddenly though is TV the first
generation of TV raised people came of
age in the 60s and the 70s and as that
happened the writing became slowly
became jazzier and snappier and shorter
because you had to hang on to these
people just to get them through a story
you had to find ways to keep their
attention and with this happened on and
on and on and the change came slowly
though because frankly most of the older
pre TV writers had to make way for a new
generation who proves brains were
programmed to that new order and you
don't you just can't relearn your
approach to reading and writing and
thinking once you reach a certain age
you just have to die off and let the
people who grew up with a different
wiring take over and generally people do
not like to think about this they're not
fond of it I can tell you when the
internet first came into our lives when
I went to the 96 convention it was the
first time I think
The Times brought the internet with them
people were there at that time god it
was like for card tables but five
billion wires coming out of everything
all over the place and these people were
sitting there typing and some of the
older guys would walk by and would
accidentally pull out the plugs this
happened many times I mean these poor
people were just completely being pulled
out there all the time it was a you know
they were it was a new world and they
knew it was coming and they knew they
weren't going to be part of it just as I
know I'm not going to be part of the
thing that happens next right now most
internet-based writing is basically
print writing with shorter paragraphs
but in the end it's going to have to be
a totally different animal a new
generation of readers doesn't have the
attention span of a gnat anymore they
have the attention span of a little baby
net with a DD baby net their defense
they were you can't hold him for a
sentence anymore unless you really work
at them you wish they had the attention
span of a gnat gee whiz they've grown up
in a world with so many continual
distractions that reading a paragraph
reading a sentence is a commitment for
them but they are not less curious there
are no less curious and they're no less
concerned about the world around them
that the people who came before it's
just that they're going to have to be
reaped through new forms of writing with
more bells and whistles than my
generation is ever dreamed of it's going
to be really hard to figure this out
it's going to be like twittering war and
peace at them I don't know how it'll
happen but it's doable it's doable and
when people want to get their thoughts
and ideas and discoveries across they do
find a way to do it and you're going to
find a way and you're going to make
history you're going to be the ones to
do it and future generations are going
to read the stuff that people like me
road and they might be interested and I
hope they'll take notes for class on
occasion but we're not going to speak
directly to them and you will and this
is the most exciting challenge I can
imagine for people who are in love with
the written world you are going to do it
you're going to change the universe and
it's entirely for you and I am so
envious but all I can say to you is go
and do it
knock their socks off and have a great
graduation day thanks very much
if you do
thanks Gail that was wonderful not all
of you who were here who are here now
were here yesterday at miller theatre
for our student award ceremony because
this is a much bigger haul so for those
of you who did not have the pleasure of
being there yesterday i'm going to
quickly recap our student awards so
here's how this works i'm going to read
a pretty long list and and hold your
applause do not applaud for each
individual named i read and then by the
time i get to the end of the long list
you'll have a decent number of people
standing and then you'll applaud you
know with great passion and gusto okay
so these are the names of those who
graduated from with honors Sarah butcher
mavic Sasha chavkin yay lunch in
frederick dryer lindsay dunsmuir sarah
hamden artists henderson Andrew Cashner
lauren kirchner christopher lives a
francis McInnis Joel mirrors ada molnar
stephen NESN Charisse fom leslie picker
Mary plumber Susannah papak Scott sell
shreena Sinha Emma silvers John Tucker
Kim Bell see Lisa one Annan Rory Weiss
board mara Zepeda so let's have one
round of applause with emphasis a lot
more
ok so now we'll do Awards round to those
were the honors in class these are a
specific awards so again don't applaud
until I say it's okay and then you know
really lose it and please stand when I
call your name the Richard T Baker Bronx
Inc award it goes to or went to Sarah
butch from of itch the Richard T Baker
Brooklyn Inc award went other know
Brooklyn Inc award went to marry plumber
the Richard T Baker Colombian new
service award megan gibson the richard
baker magazine production award Joel
Mears the Richard Baker magazine
production award Francis McGuinness the
Richard Baker magazine writing award
Lisa held second Richard T Baker
magazine writing award John Tucker and
the final Richard Baker Award for
literary journalism to lauren kirchner
then Nona Blake Ian award for literary
criticism David Kessel the Richard blood
scholarship Sam Fellman the Judy f
Crichton documentary award precita
sharma and Jessica hopper the Phillip
Greer award Lindsay Dunsmore and manga
Slotin the Arthur Harris prize for best
master of arts thesis finalists David's
acts and Carrie Peyton Dahlberg winner
rohini Mullen the Robert Herron award
shefali kulkarni the Fred no let's hold
it back the Fred Hechinger journalism
education award Marisa Miley and rubs
skibo the Horgan prizes for excellence
in critical science writing third place
Leonard schoenberger second place
Delphine Reuter first place Sasha
chavkin outstanding journalism
editorial-writing Joel mirrors Peter
Keller editing prize Althea phone John
Connor broadcast journalism award
Charice fom linton fellowship in book
writing artist
Anderson and Nathaniel Adams Melvin
mentor award Jason Marshall lars erik
nelson prize Sam Fellman photo
journalism award Diana Marcos Ian and
Chris geyer saket award maria del Mar
cabra valero and daniel roberts Henry
and Taylor award Francis McKenna's James
a Wexler award for international
reporting artist Henderson James a
Wexler award for national reporting
catch of wachtel James a Wexler award
for local reporting Summerside e lewis
Winnick prize Lauren kerchner digital
media interactive designs Shane snow
excellence in the digital media
interactive workshop Lisa one and then
digital medium multimedia storytelling
scott's cell and andrew cashner digital
media visual storytelling lim we Lee
Jung Nightly News workshop Tammy Mutasa
and Kelly koopmans radio workshop Katie
Simon and Lindsey dunsmuir video
storytelling workshop Edward tion so
let's have a round for them
finally we have I want to repeat the
names of the winners of the awards to
the top highest ranking students in the
class again I'll read this short list
and then you'll applauded wildly at the
end the Davis David Marcus Idol award
went to Mara Zepeda the pulitzer
travelin fellowships parts of part of
joseph pulitzer's founding legacy to the
school went to five outstanding students
to enable them to travel and study
abroad one Pulitzer traveling fellowship
is presented to a student who wants to
spend a career as an arts critic and
that fellowship went to Katherine Clark
second fellowship went to Sasha chavkin
third fellowship they have a misprint
here who John John Tucker sorry Sasha
your name was on his second and third by
misprint so John stand up fourth Rory
Weiss board and the final one and the
essentially our valedictorian Lauren
kerchner big applause for them
well if we had the speeches before we
award the degrees it is far from certain
that you'd stay for the speeches so we
have the speeches first but now we
actually will award the degrees and to
do that I will invite to the podium our
Dean of Student Affairs and may
pronunciations are sweet screen of asin
to this to the award winners
congratulations and to the parents to
some of the parents in the room want you
to know I didn't get I didn't get honors
either when I graduated to the students
i want to i want to remind you that i
told you the year would travel fast nine
months for our ma students ms students
for nine months for ms students ten
months for our ma students two or three
years for our part timers and multiple
years for our PhD students but of course
i have to invite you back already to
another event orientation is on friday
for our part-time students and if you're
free for 30 friday student center
reception it is now my honor to
introduce you to graduates from 40
countries and 35 states some of the
names you here tonight today will be
unfamiliar to you and there it's for
three reasons one some students have
chosen a more traditional form and
pronunciation of their name as opposed
to the more Americanized version that
you might have heard second some
students chose their full formal names
in all their glory rather than the
menore nickname e-type names you knew
them by but the third and biggest
reasons some of these names might not
sound familiar to you is that simply i
will get them wrong so on apologize to
the parents aunts uncles grandparents
and anyone else these students might
named after and now on to our program
I'd like to invite assistant dean of
students Melanie Huff to help distribute
the diplomas
and I know many of you have a trick at
these things you sit there with your
program and you know by alphabetical
order when your student comes up that
won't work today we're doing it by
alphabetical order of their main
professor rather than the list you have
in front of you just to keep it
interesting so I'm going to invite
different professors to come up and
present the award so you'll just have to
listen carefully through each one
because you never know when that
students coming up first we're going to
present our degrees for a master of
science candidates oktober 2009 those
will be presented first by professor
john dingus and yes it is appropriate to
applaud our each professor as they come
up from New York New York insiya Sayid
our next presenter will be Dean bill
grew skin from Miami Florida Liz Bale
Matthews our next presenter will be
professor David clay tell from castro
valley california ms Gonzaga Darby our
next presenter will be professor Ruth
paddler from Seattle Washington Julia
maze our next presenter will be
professor Beth White House from irvine
california DW Gibson we will now present
an MS degree from februari februari 2010
the presenter will be professor Ruth
paddler from San Francisco California
Natalie Ehrlich
and I want extra applause for these
folks they've been here with us for some
time our PhD graduates in communications
our PhD in communications the awards
will be presented by Professor todd
gitlin
from New York City john william kelly
from hellsing denmark Rasmus Kleiss
Nielsen from Iowa City Iowa Benjamin
Peters next will present our ma Master
of Arts in journalism specializing in
arts business politics or science and
our first presenters in the arts program
a professor's elisa solomon and david
haye do from Ballymena northern ireland
kathryn clark from Newton Massachusetts
Abigail Goldsmith draclyn Jones from
London in the United Kingdom her precor
garhwal from New Delhi India via kerala
none Dineen I are from New York City bow
on from Brooklyn New York Laura
Catherine Raskin
from Beirut Lebanon Shireen sod from
Auckland New Zealand Nicola Shepherd
from Philadelphia Pennsylvania Thomas
Stoker from San Jose California Sylvia
ooh yaaaaah from Hartford Connecticut
Curtis Michael Wong our next presenters
in the business major our professor
sylvia nasar and James Stewart from
Manchester Connecticut Victoria Finkel
from Grand Island Nebraska Jonathan
Arthur Lentz from Montreal Canada Angus
Lotan from mendoza argentina Rafael
Mateus ruiz from hong kong china ivy
from Vancouver British Columbia jeff
john roberts from San Francisco
California Katie roof from Taganrog
Russia Daria solo viola from Singapore
michelle tay our next presenters in the
politics major our professors Tom Etzel
and Alexander still owe from Brooklyn
New York Colin Asher bossy okay d from
London in the United Kingdom Greg
callous
from Washington DC Eliza Lindsay gray
from Oslo Norway even Gustafson from
Prague in the Czech Republic marketa
hull bacova from baramulla kashmir tariq
near from bangalore india rohini mohan
from karachi pakistan ali mustafa
from Mount Holly New Jersey Eric Parker
from Calgary Canada David perlick from
New York City Shane dear a seagull from
Oslo Norway hi detox dolls a set from
madrid espana aitana Vargas from Ghent
Belgium Walter / Sheldon from Melbourne
Australia Katya Wachtel our presenters
in the science program are professors
Marguerite Holloway and Jonathan weiner
from Guildford Connecticut David
Funkhouser
from kampala uganda O&K dengue from New
York City Peggy Mihelich from New York
City Marissa Miley from LA los alamitos
California amita pusher from Danville
California Laura Peterson from
Sacramento California Carrie Payton
dahlberg from Berlin deutschland Jana
schluter from Washington DC David Zacks
next we'll be presenting our night
badgett fellows they'll receive a master
of science degree and a certificate in
economics and business journalism the
certificates and degrees will be
presented by Professor terry thompson
director of the night budget program
from San Salvador El Salvador Raul
Diego's from New York City Martha
Alexandra grave owl from Melbourne
Australia jackson hewitt from New York
City via Wales Roland Jones from Newton
Massachusetts a me true veiny Paley from
Doylestown Pennsylvania JoEllen Chapman
perry from newark delaware robert weary
from San Francisco California Nicole
Cherie swung from New York New York
christine young next will be recognizing
our Spencer fellows will receive a
certificate from the Spencer fellowship
in education journalism and these will
be presented by Professor Linnell
Hancock
from Brooklyn New York Sarah garland
from silver spring maryland Elizabeth
green from Brooklyn New York peg tire
and now to our master of science in
journalism candidates
our first presenters are professor Lenny
borin and dodi cient are from Portsmouth
Great Britain James dimelo from Perry
froze yasmin guerre des from bellevue
washington kelly lynn koopmans from
Philadelphia Pennsylvania Rory crests
Weiss board from Albany Georgia Erin Lee
from Philadelphia Pennsylvania Daniel
hyatt Lieberman from Harare Zimbabwe
tamaki suoh tammy mutasa from Orlando
Florida Carmen Perez from Leawood Kansas
leslie picker from new orleans louisiana
brandon duncan Walker from Youngstown
Ohio Abigail Wendell from London in the
United Kingdom you polka ago Yibo our
next presenter will be professor Eleanor
Cabral
from Karachi Pakistan fahd farooqi from
Philadelphia Pennsylvania Brian Armand
Graham from New Orleans Louisiana Renee
trechelle Henry from eastchester New
York Peter Coleman for murfreesboro
tennessee aaron lee macbeth from los
angeles california joining their mother
on stage Sophie and Sam joined by Susan
Sawyer's
from Concord Massachusetts Spencer
wilking our next presenters will be
professor cabral and professor rodel
Lipton from Bloomfield Hills Michigan
Leslie Elise Atkins from London England
and Oh Alfred from Monrovia California
Ryan Nicole blackshear from arcadia
california Angela Chen from Franklin
Virginia John I shied from cranberry New
Jersey Leslie Elizabeth heart from
London in the united kingdom Alexandra
Sophie King from Chandler Arizona
Christopher Livesay from miami florida a
mandolin massage from Upland California
sheriff Emmitt ma dude
from Calgary Canada Charice come from
New York City Monica watch an attack
from New York City Michelle shocker from
Perry froze saskya vandoorne from
Ramallah Palestine Rania zaban a our
next presenters will be professors and
Cooper and Betsy west from Sacramento
California acabei Makonnen Ohio from
varna bulgaria knew she knew sabali on
from Syosset longisland bradley gallo
from perry froze kettavan gorgeous thani
from Rockford Michigan Jennifer Howard
from Queens New York a veteran of the
Air Force jahangir irani
from Des Moines Iowa Jane Julie from
London in the United Kingdom Kieran
moodley from Anchorage Alaska Mary Jo
Ann Elizabeth plumber from Mill Valley
California Zach Seward from Detroit
Michigan amica Smith our next presenters
are professors June cross and Laura muha
from frankford deutschland Danielle
bench
from Davenport Iowa david andrew collins
from newton massachusetts chao deng from
alexandria virginia via palestine dunya
kamal from Rochester Minnesota Kirk
lucky from Moscow Russia dianna marcos
Ian from Los Alamitos California sanaaz
Mishkin poor from Tenafly New Jersey
Tereus Novak from Lahore Pakistan aiza
omar from silver spring maryland Janelle
Richards from Munich deutschland Leonard
shoenberger from New Delhi India shreya
sinha from falls church virginia
angelica spanos dias from wilmington
delaware Courtney Agnes adoro street our
next presenter will be professor ari
Goldman from Portland Oregon Mariah
Jessica summers from Seattle Washington
Megan Bradley Thomas pump one more time
from Seattle Washington Megan Bradley
Thompson
on our next presenter will be professor
Linnell hancock from bump from she'll be
joined by Professor Barbara cantera wits
Barbara kantrowitz there you go from
Bombay India month about girl from
Philadelphia Pennsylvania alex berg from
ada michigan Connor bowls from Golden
Colorado Frederick dryer from queens new
york Maya Ephraim from Dublin Ireland
donal griffin from Munich deutschland
Wanda Helmand from driftwood Texas
Matthew hustling from Watertown New York
Alec Johnson from hillsboro oregon
shefali Sunil Kulkarni
from San Luis Potosi Mexico Jose Leyva
from Clarks Summit Pennsylvania Leslie
menorah from ramsey New Jersey Amanda
Kathleen stub from Istanbul Turkey
Mustafa McGee brow from Cairo Egypt some
Sarah Oh mawali from Bristol Florida
Carmen Williams our next presenter will
be professor Tammy Lou be from New York
New York lauren brown from falls church
virginia Jeffrey Alexander Dooley from
Edinburgh Scotland Lindsay dunsmuir from
khartoum sudan raya Elwha Teague kamari
from Minneapolis Minnesota a veteran of
the US Navy Samuel Lewis Spellman from
Toronto Canada Barnaby guys Wyler from
Athens Greece via Kuwait Sarah in hamden
from London England Amanda Julius from
for a bush New York Alison Martin from
Forest Hills New York sudeep mukerji
from gilroy California Veronica Phillips
from Singapore way luan soon from Verona
italia a leech a Sperry from Chicago
Illinois Mickey steal from San Jose
California van to our next presenters
will be professors dale maharaj and
jessica bruderer
from Baltimore Maryland Jennifer Dana
brookland from Phoenix Arizona Amanda
Lin Chan from New Delhi India de rnal
dhingra from Brooklyn New York Patrick
Egan from New York New York Dustin
Fitzharris from addis ababa ethiopia
salam Gaborik Eden from New York New
York della Louise SL from Regina Canada
lorica sisto from Leavenworth Kansas
daraa l miles from Princeton New Jersey
Charles mosteller from Tulsa Oklahoma
Denver Brian Morris enix from Larchmont
New York Dan Rosen from Seattle
Washington Calvin Powell Schneider from
San Rafael California Rachel Stern from
sending hamburg Luxembourg Rebecca
Thomas
from Plattsburgh New York Kim belsay
from Brooklyn New York Michael Ventura
from New York City bill wiese road from
Kildare Ireland bari jay white our next
presenter will be professor judith
Matloff from New York New York Sierra
Brown in San Diego California Michelle
Casteel yo from Cairo Egypt Noah mohamed
el hana we from washington d.c illegally
from mumbai india so t go t potty from
Amman Jordan Oh Marcus wowie from London
England Natasha Lennard from Springfield
Virginia Emily Russo Miller from Phoenix
Arizona Benedict Moran from Alton Alaska
Dean Myers from Tokyo Japan shiori
mochizuki from Montclair New Jersey
Michael Ratliff from Alexandria Virginia
Angelo rotten Darrow from Singapore
ruchika dolci on from Montreal Canada
Evan Wexler
our next presenter is Professor mirta
ojito from New York New York Nathaniel
Adams from eglin West Virginia Matthew
big tell from Milford Connecticut Taylor
Catherine Brown from millbrae California
Candace Chan from Beijing China alone 10
New Orleans Louisiana Lenore Cho from
New Delhi India Radhika Gupta from Fort
Collins Colorado Ryan hatch from
Istanbul Turkey Elif Inge
from st. Catherine Jamaica Shauna kay
Lester from Singapore lim we young from
Des Moines Iowa Jeanette Newman from
Harrisburg Pennsylvania Carolyn vanessi
from Mumbai India siddharth philip
because of a family emergency he's not
able to be with us but we're going to
read out his name anyway from New York
City Hamid ruzek from Fort Lauderdale
Florida Valentina Rodriguez from short
hills new jersey Christian Yarnell our
next presenter is Professor Ruth pad or
from Abu Dhabi in the United Arab
Emirates Tala o rama he accompanied by
his daughter Maya is a veteran of the
United States Army from Maracaibo
Venezuela via Texas Diego aparicio from
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania Victor Lee from
Melbourne Australia Claire mcdougal from
Waterloo Canada Katie Moyes from Reno
Nevada Paula neudorf from Brooklyn New
York Susie pupcake from Omaha Nebraska
Bayon Raji from wilmette illinois
Caroline rotstein from Dallas Texas
summer sadi from New Haven Connecticut
scott anthony cell from New York New
York Jonathan Shia from Toronto Canada
Zachary Snyderman from Aberdeen Scotland
Ian Thompson
from columbus ohio
from Columbus Columbus Ohio Tracy John
wolf from New York New York grace Lewis
Williams from our next presenter is
Professor Sandeep at way
from Calcutta India serene Abu Bakr from
Norland Louisiana diya Chacko from
Brooklyn New York Darius Dixon from New
York New York ashley morgan ferry from
Toronto Canada Colin Fleming from
huntington new york Lauren Beatty
Kirchner from cold frost Sheen labai
from victoria canada Andrew Lampard from
Vancouver Canada Francis mcinnes from
Scotch Plains New Jersey Alan Jeffrey
Neuhauser from Houston Texas Victoria
rossi from Windhoek Namibia torsten
sheer from Princeton New Jersey Robert
Christopher's Cabo from Albany
California Emma silvers from Tel Aviv
Israel yo of sivan from Berlin
deutschland Francisca shaven our next
two presenters are professor Robin
reisig and professor Billy gorta
from greenbelt maryland Danielle Douglas
from queens new york david physique asst
from Brooklyn New York Matthew Hennessey
from Brooklyn New York Mario Nicasio
Lopez from Cambridge Massachusetts ADA
Milner from battleboro Vermont Steven
Nissen from East Northport New York
Scott Ulster from Evergreen Colorado
Bradley warrants tell our next presenter
is Professor atty Rimmer
from Athens Greece Nicoli Apostolou from
New York New York Sasha chavkin from
Wilmington Delaware Sonja dasgupta from
Montezuma New Mexico Christopher Guyer
from coral springs florida sonam vaghela
missouri city texas ashley r harris
abilene texas daniel james johnson kim
from new york new york david Kessel from
Toronto Canada Stephanie Marcus from
Brussels Belgium Delphine writer from
clifton park new york a veteran of the
US Army john ryan from Chicago Illinois
aliza celerio from Spartanburg South
Carolina Lauren saucer
from Brooklyn New York jeffy spodek
lamotte lawrenceville New Jersey Ryan
Tracy from New York New York santhi
bhardwaj our next presenters are
professor Christopher Scanlon and Pam
Frederick from Denver Colorado Spencer
Bailey from Shreveport Louisiana Amy
britain from johannesburg south africa
Lindsey shoe tell from Fort Myers
Florida artists Henderson from
mountainside New Jersey Alexander
Melville Robertson huts from bartlett
illinois sujit kumar from edison new
jersey radhika Marya from Harare
Zimbabwe Watson I moot a
from Bermuda Claire O'Connor from
Karachi Pakistan Mahalakshmi shiraz we
from Seattle Washington Ruth Snyder from
bronxville New York Marlo stern from
pachuca Mexico Paulina Villegas from San
Francisco California Alexandra walled
horn our next presenter is Professor
Michael Shapiro
from manhattan new york Christopher
Alessi from Birmingham Michigan Chris
Robert Christopher Henderson from
Overland Kansas Terri Bane's from Queens
New York stefanos Dennis Chen from
Bangalore India KS nikhil kumar from
Pleasantville New York Meredith Matson
Kennedy from Calgary Canada Miranda Lynn
from San Francisco California Jack Jose
Murchison in padova italia Alicia pero
lo from Bowling Green Virginia Sarah
Raven Portlock from Newton Massachusetts
Daniel benjamin roberts from
Gaithersburg Maryland ashika sing from
Richmond Virginia Derek Bryson Taylor
from Lima Peru Katerina valdivieso from
Santa Fe New Mexico Mara's mother Zepeda
Roma Italian netanya zevy
our next presenter is Professor Paulus
fan
from Richmond Virginia Marvin Anderson
from Enfield Connecticut Sarah wipro
butcher movic from Paree frost Cecile do
a song from Memphis Tennessee Ashley Fox
from New York New York Rachel Horowitz
from Juno Beach Florida Rebecca Duvall
from Suffern New York Andrew Samuel
Cashner from Toronto Canada timki lads
from Singapore Shareen Pathak from New
York City Samuel Griffin Petula from
Lookout Mountain Tennessee a veteran of
the US Army Nate Rawlings from New Delhi
India sonal Shah from Idaho Falls Idaho
Shane David snow from Ottawa Canada
Joshua tapper from Minneapolis Minnesota
Lisa 1nn from New York New York Suzanne
Weinstock
from Karachi Pakistan honey Yusuf our
next presenter is Professor Richard Wald
from Sacramento California Winifred
Louise Andrews from Ottawa Canada
Natalya barge from morgantown west
virginia jonathan coal from Brooklyn New
York Althea Fung from Saskatoon Canada
megan gibson from Boston Massachusetts
Bessie King from Eden Prairie Minnesota
Vadim love rusic from topsham main l
enjoy london from costa mesa california
chasing Saleem Marshall from Sydney
Australia Joel mirrors
from Los Angeles California nooshin
rashidian from Lahore Pakistan Sonia
remand from Paree France Isabel shaper
from Queens New York Caroline chin from
gig harbor Washington Andrew Tobin from
Brooklyn New York hunter whopper from
Nogales Arizona a veteran of the US Army
Daniel Wolff ax Rome addis ababa
ethiopia nami Abraham from Amman Jordan
summer as a day from Tustin California
candy Chang oh I'm sorry I'm sorry our
file presenters professor Beth White
House this is candice cheng
from Union City New Jersey Carmen cocido
from Red Bank New Jersey Sharon
McCluskey from New York New York Joseph
Pisani from White Plains New York Jenny
chillon from brookline massachusetts
Rebecca title from Philadelphia
Pennsylvania John Hayden Tucker from
Washington DC a veteran of the US Army
accompanied by Tuesday luis carlos
montalvan
ladies and gentlemen he got a Don villip
two ladies and gentlemen the class of
you